Remasters have become an accepted part of
video games in recent years. Older games are
given a fresh coat of paint and sometimes
even gameplay tweaks and the released on modern
systems. This year alone has seen some pretty
big remasters including BioShock, Call of
Duty 4: Modern Warfare, and The Elder Scrolls
V: Skyrim. But let me ask you a question.
Can remasters change too much?
Because the reality is that these remasters
aren’t the same game you played all those
those years ago. They feature different textures,
employ modern day tech that simply wasn’t
possible back then. These aren’t upscale
transfers of an VHS to blu-ray, these are
Star Wars Special Editions. So what happens
when these updated versions alter too much
of the original art style and makes gameplay
tweaks that fundamentally make the game different?
The BioShock remaster has been panned by fans
for numerous reasons including limited graphics
options, changes to art and graphics, missing
audio, and somehow being even more buggy than
the original PC port. But I want to focus
on the changes in art, because BioShock’s
art style is probably its most recognizable
aspect and core to its identity.
The changes made in the remaster are pretty
subtle and average person will probably not
notice them. Things like added seaweed in
the bathysphere ride. This statue of Andrew
Ryan has been remodeled, this red carpet has
been removed, and for some reason the floor
tiles in this room have been rotated. The
lighting is different in places, and the textures
are “less wet,” which is to say they are
no longer glossy and the feeling of being
in a damp city at the bottom of the ocean
is somewhat diminished. And the truth is a
lot people will not notice or even care about
this small changes, but for some, small details
like this is important because you are playing
with people's nostalgia, and odd changes like
the removable of this carpet for seemingly
no reason other than to make it different
just feels pointless. It's like when George
Lucas added this rock in front of R2-D2. It
doesn’t run the movie of anything, but just…
why?
But maybe carpet changes and not wet textures
feels too nitpicky for you. How about a more
obvious and dramatic change like the iOS mobile
remake of Final Fantasy 6? Here’s original
Final Fantasy for the Super Nintendo. Now
for the mobile version they stretched the
image, The backgrounds appear to be traced
over. The character sprites are completely
replaced. Everything is then given this blurry
smudge effect. And then the textbox is replaced
with modern UI, font, and a detailed character
portrait. The final effect is a combination
of disparate styles that lack the cohesiveness
of the orignal pixel art. Rather then rebuild
the whole game with a new artist vision, we
get this frankenstein photoshop, which mistreats
the original art and the artists who made
it.
But visuals aren’t the only thing remasters
add, some also add gameplay changes as well,
which makes sense. Controls and certain mechanics
can quickly become outdated in the fast moving
world of video games, so wanting to freshen
them up for modern players can be a good idea.
Nintendo’s been doing with with all their
remasters of the 3D Zelda games, addressing
complaints with the originals and fixing them
where they can. Stuff like adding a faster
sail in The Wind Waker HD to cut down on the
long sailing time, or changing the “Song
of Double Time” in Majora’s Mask 3DS which
likes you skip to any hour of the day, instead
of just the nearest half day. And of course
the most infamous issues of the Iron Boots
in Ocarina of Time’s Water Temple, which
in the original game you had to tediously
open the menu every time to equip and unequip,
but in the 3DS remaster was changed to a simple
button press. But you also need to be careful
in what we change. A video game and its mechanics
are tied to each other, and it's possible
to unintentionally alter the experience too
much.
Such is the case with Doom 3’s remaster,
‘BFG Edition.” The Doom 3 has a controversial
flashlight mechanic, because you could not
use it and hold a weapon and the same time.
Many players did not care for this, leading
to the creation of the famous ducttape mod.
So when 2012’s remaster of Doom 3, titled
“BFG edition”, came around, the bold move
was made to made this mod official, removing
the original flashlight mechanic from the
game entirely. The problem is that even if
you didn’t like it, Doom 3 was designed
around that original flashlight. Every room
was a potential for a scare, and the comfort
you would get from being able to see with
the flashlight, came at the cost of being
able to shoot. The taking that away removes
a large part of the tension and suspense Doom
3 creates. It makes the game worse. And while
Doom 3 hasn’t aged terribly well, the flashlight
still is a unique idea that you don’t see
replicated in other games. It's a concept
whole original to Doom 3. And they just removed
it. But that's ok, because we can still load
up and enjoy original Doom 3. Well that almost
wasn’t the case.
Back when Doom 3: BFG Edition came out, Original
Doom 3 and it’s expansion were removed from
the steam store. No official reason was ever
said for why this happened, but if you want
to put on your cynic hat it could have been
because you could buy the original cheaper
and then just recreate all of BFG Edition’s
improvements with mods. The game eventually
came back to the store a month later allow
consumers the choice in which version to buy,
but this isn’t always the case. If you want
to play the horror classics Silent Hill 2
and 3, you’re only choice is to buy the
HD remasters, which have been heavily criticized
as rushed port jobs. That iOS version of Final
Fantasy 6? That's the version that got ported
to steam.
And this is becoming a real issue with games
on digital stores. Publishers seem interested
in only having one version of their game on
a storefront, so if multiple version exist
they tend to pick the most recent version.
A perfect example of this is the original
Resident Evil. Resident Evil 1 has numerous
ports and updates over the years, and even
a full on excellent remake. But if you still
want to play the PS1 classic it's available
digitally on the playstation store. Except
that's actually not the original release of
the game. It’s the “Resident Evil: Director’s
Cut Dual Shock ver.” which was released
over a year after the original game and features
added content such as arranged mode, which
swaps around all the puzzle items. It's certainly
the most feature rich version which is probably
why it’s the one on the store but R E D
C D S V also features a completely different
soundtrack from the original, one that is
considered worse by the fans. But because
this is the only version that got picked to
be preserved digitally, that original soundtrack
will eventually be lost to time, and this
will be replaced with this.
More so than any other media, games change,
especially in today’s era of updates and
patches. It’s impossible for someone starting
Destiny today to be able to play and experience
the original vanilla release from 2014. It's
ok and even important for games to change
and for devs to be allowed to make those changes,
but it's also important to respect the original
versions of these games and gives players
choice in the versions they can play. When
the original System Shock was finally available
digitally, Developer Nightdive studios put
out the “Enhanced Edition”, which updated
the graphics and improved the controls, a
welcome addition because those original controls
are garbage.But it also comes with the classic
version of the game for those that want to
experience it. Nightdive is also the team
responsible for the upcoming System Shock
Reboot.
And then there are games that allow you to
switch between original and updated controls,
audio, and graphics in the game themselves.
Games like the Halo Anniversaries, and the
LucasArts adventure game remasters. You press
a button and suddenly you’re swapping between
10 years of video game progress. Apart from
it just being a really cool gimmick, it acts
as a historical showcase.
And that’s what remasters should be. Celebrations
of these games and the time and history that
comes with them, which also means being willing
to showing the flaws, rather than sweep them
under the rug. I want remasters to be the
Blade Runner box set that comes with all 5
cuts, even if I will never watch that theatrical
version. Because preserving and respecting
games is important, and we could be doing
a lot better job at it.